ganz genau also wir haben ja viele
aussagen heute von der labor aufgehört
das mit dem krieg das kann man
vielleicht noch sagen okay das ist eine
mögliche operation das sehen wir anders
aber er hat auch über diesen angriff auf
die geburtsklinik gestern in mario pohl
gesprochen und was er da geliefert hat
war dass er gesagt hat es ist es gab
diesen angriff überhaupt nicht auf eine
geburtsklinik es gab keine angriffe auf
ein militärisches ziel und es gab da
auch keine frauen und kinder dann fragt
man sich was sind das für frauen kinder
und das hat dann seine seine seinen
apparat sein außenministerium und auch
die verschiedenen botschaft in den
sozialen medien betrieben die haben
behauptet und wir sehen uns hier das
sind schauspieler da wurden schauspieler
hingebracht von den ukrainern um dort
etwas um dort etwas darzustellen dass
dort ein angriff stattgefunden hat haben
also gefunden dass eine von denen hat
gemodelt und hat mit instagram account
und diese instagram account wurde als
beweis dafür genommen dass das alles
nicht stimmt und da setzt mein punkt an
was wir sehen also einmal dass die
russische führung propaganda macht gut
dass sie machen das ist ihr ding aber
wir sehen dass diese propaganda von
unfassbar vielen kanälen verbreitet
werden von der russischen regierung und
das verstehe ich nicht wie kann das noch
sein wie kann es sein dass twitter
beispielsweise in russland blockiert ist
aber eine russische botschaft über
twitter die welt vergiften darf mit
dieser propaganda behaupten darf dass
diese frau dort beispielsweise eine
schauspielerin ist wie kann das sein
dass facebook in russland blockiert wird
aber über facebook alle möglichen troll
und so weiter accounts aus sankt
petersburg und co hier gift verbreiten
dürfen und zu guter letzt das gleiche
gilt auch für die russische medien ich
verstehe weiterhin nicht dass wir es
akzeptieren dass deutsche welle
beispielsweise in russland blockiert
wird und er tdi weiterhin senden darf in
deutschland sowohl auf der homepage als
auch über fernsehen und aline
jahresprogramm was über viele kanäle zu
erreichen ist deshalb mein punkt hier
diese propaganda muss aufhören wir
müssen dafür sorgen unsere
bundesregierung muss dafür sorgen dass
diese propaganda wenn sie von der
russische regierung verbreitet wird
nicht auch noch auf englisch französisch
spanisch deutsch und so weiter in alle
kanäle weiter geflutet kann wird und wir
sehen es bei einem teil der
öffentlichkeit wirkt dass ein teil der
öffentlichkeit wir sehen es auch immer
wie immer in den kommentaren zu unseren
dingen die wir veröffentlichen zu
unseren berichterstattung anteil der
öffentlichkeit glaubt es gibt keinen
russischen angriff auf die ukraine und
was wir hier sehen in dem video was
neben beläuft sind schauspieler die vom
ukrainischen nazis missbraucht wurden um
mir einen russischen angriff
solange so was bei uns gesendet werden
darf
verliere ich so ein bisschen meinen
glauben an den rechtsstaat auch in
deutschland und an die wehrhafte
demokratie
herr kubicki geht die bundesregierung
nicht scharf genug gegen diese art der
informationsverbreitung vor jetzt
zunächst einmal hatte diesen große
botschaft in london gelöst nach fünf
stunden vielen dank ja noch einmal wann
immer man dass das etikett ist neben
brauchen gewisse zeit mehr austreten ob
das tatsächlich jetzt ist oder auch
nicht ich warne dringend davor wir sind
ein rechtsstaat der der meinungsfreiheit
in besonderer weise wirkliches artikel
des grundgesetzes geht für jedermann und
ich waren auch dringend davor jetzt so
zu tun als das müssen wir genauso
reagieren die die russen die verbieten
dass man kriegt nicht mehr krieg nennen
davon wir verbieten jetzt das russische
russische informationen irgendwie
eingespeist wird abgesehen davon dass
wir uns auch gar nicht komplett
unterbinden können es sei denn wir
würden uns von allen
informationskanälen im social media
bereich komplett abnabeln was einfach
nicht funktioniert auch nicht geht was
wir tun können ist durch offensive
aufklärung darauf hinzuweisen dass die
tatsächlich in der propaganda maschine
dabei ist ein krieg der ein krieg ist
weder zu leugnen oder aber in die
falsche richtung zu verherrlichen das
ist so eine aufgabe der medien wie bild
bild am sonntag
was den ball zu den medien
trotz erster dokumentieren gerade weil
man das auch teilweise er überprüfen
kann darstellen kann dass ein krieg
stattfindet der wirklich unmenschlich
ist der auch völkerrechtswidrig ist der
auch kriegsverbrechen beinhaltet und
dass man dokumentiert das ist nicht
geschehen und dass man unter umständen
weniger für verantwortlich sind
irgendwann mal zur verantwortung ziehen
kann so wie es den ganzen internationale
strafgerichtshof dagegen werde ich schon
gerade tut aber jetzt zu sagen alles was
uns jetzt momentan nicht gefällt an
informationen nachrichten muss verboten
werden halte ich für falsch das muss
entlarvt werden zu dokumentieren dass
wir als westliche welt denn die
meinungsfreiheit hoch achten und davon
ausgehen dass informationen dann auch
valide sind und mich einfach zu
propagandazwecken als lügen getan daher
kommen also mein eindruck ist dass die
russen also den krieg schon längst
verloren haben also den krieg und bilder
und um stimmung
also das reicht das schon zu sehen auf
der einen seite dieses krokodil wie la
france ja der wiso notdürftig noch
zusammengehalten wird oder den geboten
putin das gesicht über breitflächige
wird und man denkt irgendwann platzt der
an diesen immer länger werden den
tischen ja ich glaube der letzte mal hat
er jetzt den rekord gebrochen metern ich
habe 32 oder seine
zentralbankchef in sitzen der war noch
länger so und dagegen zielinski
im gespräch mit ronzheimer oder
oder in diesen in diesen videos
übernächtigt ein junger mann der seinem
volk mut zuspricht ich weiß gar nicht
dafür dann das letzte mal putin
rausgekommen ist man weiß ja nicht mal
wo er sich aufhält wahrscheinlich in
irgendwelchen stadien willen oder
bunkern die schon stadien gebaut hat
weil er angst hatte vergiftet zu werden
also ich dieses diese videos die wir
gesehen haben mit diesen aeroflot
mitarbeiterin da ist ja mittlerweile
fraglich ob er überhaupt jemals gesessen
hat oder ob wir ihn da nicht rein
geschnitten haben was man sieht wie
seine hand durchs mikrofon ist wie
aeroflot mitarbeiterin war auch er eine
sicherheitsfrage so also
insofern also ich glaube wir kriegen ja
die sieht man in russland nicht gesehen
für alle aber die rebellen rücken aber
dieser wir reden jetzt gerade von rt
deutschland also sozusagen twitter
deutschland twitter europas wird der
welt so und da
das gibt auch hier verrückte die
wahrscheinlich an putin die daumen
drücken ja aber das ist wirklich eine
kleine verschwindende minderheit also da
wird man einander noch bei der afg
finden
und doch ganz links bei der linkspartei
aber
so also dass das ist diese nation hat
sich zum welt paria gemacht er setzt
also nicht mehr der chinese hat ja in
dem gespräch mit makro und unser
bundeskanzler irgendein versuch
unternommen
zu sagen da ja das ist ja nicht so
schlimm
oder man muss die russen verstehen also
also an diesen fakten
besteht außerhalb von russland kein
zweifel so gut dass beim eigenen volk
sieht anders aus
da hat er nun alles abgeschnitten also
ich finde er wir sollten versuchen
den leuten in russland
unsere information zugänglich zu machen
wie auch immer
wird ja auch den einer anderen
vielleicht dort geben der gerne mal 51
sender sowie damals ja bei der bbc 19 44
mehrwert wie die welt sich wirklich
eigentlich dreht
weil wir ihn findest du das in der
ukraine diese diskussionen die wir hier
gerade fühlen auf der einen seite die
forderung von julian der ganz klar sagt
solche informationen dürfen hier in
deutschland nicht verbreitet werden aber
auch herr kubicki der sagt die aufgabe
von journalisten ist es diese zu
entlarven und nicht dass diese
informationen gestoppt werden ist ein
feiner grat
ja das ist ein schmaler grat was ich
aber bei der diskussion interessant
finde dass bei twitter und facebook der
sturm aufs kapital gereicht hat um
donald trump überall rauszuschmeißen und
rauszuwerfen und zu blockieren twitter
ist er nicht mehr facebook ist nicht
mehr und viele kanäle auch der auch der
russische staatspräsident putin hat
einen zwar nicht personalisierten aber
einen staatspräsidenten kanal und soweit
ich weiß hat darüber noch niemand
diskutiert also das sozusagen die
russischen amtsträger die gerade in
diesem moment
kinderkrankenhäuser bombardieren lassen
die dürfen da weiterhin in diesen
kanälen auftauchen deswegen ich bin
jetzt gar nicht entschlossen in der
einen oder anderen richtung nur ich
finde schon dass das wieder ein beispiel
dafür ist wie mit zweierlei maß gemessen
wird und das offenbar ja die aufregung
in den sozialen medien größer ist wenn
es um donald trump geht als würde es und
ich bleibe mir putin geht
hier lernt ja
also ich finde es immer ein bisschen
schwierig dort was herr kubicki gesagt
hat was hat das mit meinungsfreiheit zu
tun was hat denn das also wie kann man
dann sagen wir können das doch nicht so
machen wie die wollen sie sagen dass
deutsche welle ein teil der deutschen
hybriden kriegsführung gegen russland
ist das würde ich nicht sagen ich würde
aber sagen dass rt de ein teil der
russischen übrigen kriegsführung gegen
deutschland und gegen den westen ist und
insofern verstehe ich nicht dass man
sagt wir können doch nicht genauso wie
die das machen um meinungsfreiheit und
übergroß geschehen natürlich wort
meinungsfreiheit groß geschrieben und
deshalb genau deshalb sollten wir
aufpassen dass das im rahmen der
meinungsfreiheit auch berichtet werden
darf aber im rahmen des staatlich
gelenkten des informationen zur
schwächung und spaltung unserer
gesellschaft nicht gesendet werden darf
er sehen sie da keinen unterschied
also ich sehe einen unterschied zwischen
der freien presse staatliche lenken
presse aber ich habe große probleme
damit weil die gäste locker vom hocker
sagen wer den letztlich darüber
entscheiden soll was zensiert wurde was
nicht zensiert wird das ist
selbstverständlich können wir staatliche
russische sender an der ausstellung in
der europäischen union in deutschland
hindern das ist recht gar kein problem
aber andererseits lässt sich jetzt nicht
wieso wir uns dann aufregung darüber
dass die russen dann ihrerseits
staatlich finanzierte sender aus
deutschland an der sendung in
ostfinnland würden ich meine das ist
immer so eine geschichte denn der frage
der der wechselseitigen und gegenseitige
abhängigkeit ich maße mir nicht an zu
entscheiden was jetzt hin zu unterliegen
soll und was nicht abgesehen davon dass
ich mich innerlich gegen jeden gedanken
wäre wenn da jetzt so lange
relevante tatbestände erfüllt werden
also wir kommen ja die ganz merkwürdige
situation in der
wir so eine art
meinungsführerschaft beanspruchen und
nicht genau sagen können wir der letzten
starter ist das frage ist sind sie es
die bild -zeitung ist es ein rad
selbstverständlich nicht aber wenn ich
was falsch mal wieder in höhe
von niemanden beruhigen